what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm i have
a 19 hour drive so i'm just gonna pose
like some car questions
so the other day i had um
a conversation with someone who's a
little older than me he's 28 i'm 24
and we were talking about like going on
dates right so
i said that
a good first date for me is like
a coffee um
let's see i would even be cool with like
a walk like going to like a park or like
maybe not a hike someone trying to get
kidnapped like you know chipotle like
something
cheap and quick
and the reason i like this is because if
it's a first date i probably don't know
you very well so i don't want to get
roped into something that's super long
if if i get there
and we don't i don't like you
on top of that i'm someone i gotta watch
my weight i'm not trying to go to super
high calorie expensive dinners because
honestly if the food's in front of me
i'm gonna eat it like
like i'm gonna eat it and i'm i'm not
someone that like eats in moderation
it's either not gonna be in front of me
i don't know if you guys picking up what
i'm putting down anyways this guy said
that if a girl gets asked to chipotle
nowadays
she thinks that's like a cheap bad day
and i'm i'm thinking more about like
dating apps not necessarily you know
someone that you already are friends
with or you know
um
and
so my question is to the ladies that
watch me which i think there's like five
of you my audience is 97 male
um
would you guys be offended if a guy
asked you to get chipotle because i
wouldn't i would almost prefer that i
love chipotle but it could be like you
know mod pizza or something like
um
you know
small or like coffee whatever and then
have you ever asked a girl out to a
cheap date like that for a first date
you guys don't even know each other
um
and has a girl ever been offended
because i really wouldn't be but i'm
also pretty laid back so let me know
in the comments if you guys agree or you
disagree don't forget to subscribe to
the channel
and we'll talk to you guys next time